-Federal investigators executed
search warrants
at Rudy Giuliani's home
and office yesterday
and seized
his electronic devices,
which, judging from
his public behavior,
may very well contain
lots of evidence.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
Oh, Rudy, sweet Rudy, we thought
you were gone from our lives
once the Trump presidency
was over.
But now, like a baby bird
returning to its nest,
you're back.
Although I guess Rudy
looks more like the egg
before the bird hatches
or like a cartoon egg
where the legs hatch,
but that's it.
Anyway, the point is,
Trump may be out of office,
but the multiple criminal
investigations of him
and his allies are
still very much ongoing.
And yesterday, the feds provided
an emphatic reminder
of that fact
when they executed multiple
search warrants
at Rudy's home and office.
-Now to a major development
in the federal criminal
investigation
into Rudy Giuliani.
Yesterday, the FBI raided
his home and office in New York
and seized cell phones
and other electronic devices.
This investigation involves
the same U.S. attorney's office
Giuliani used to run back
in the 1980s.
-The execution of
search warrants
is an extraordinary action
for prosecutors
to take against a lawyer,
let alone a lawyer
for a former president.
The move marked
a major development
in the long-running
investigation into Mr. Giuliani,
which examines some of
the same people and conduct
that were at the center
of Mr. Trump's
first impeachment trial.
-It's unusual,
to say the least,
for prosecutors to execute
a search warrant on an attorney
because theoretically
that could uncover
privileged
attorney-client information.
-Something tells me this
is the first Rudy's
hearing of attorney-client
privilege.
He probably just thought
they meant it's a privilege
for an attorney
to actually have a client.
[ As Giuliani ] Honey,
someone finally hired me,
put on your pearls
and your dancing shoes,
going to Del Frisco's
where cousins eat free.
[ Normal voice ] And, you know,
whatever they're looking for
must be serious
if they're willing to execute
a search warrant
against any lawyer,
let alone
the president's lawyer,
who's also a former mayor
and the former head of the same
US attorney's office
is now investigating,
which is crazy.
I'd be like
if I got canned.
And then the show did
a closer look about me.
I mean, I hope you guys
at least use a flattering photo
for the over
the shoulder graphic.
Oh, come on! The one time
I sat on my own balls?
Thanks, Lloyd.
And I know this is unlikely,
but I do hope they were able
to send at least one guy
to the raid who was
working there back
when Rudy was in charge.
"Hey, boss, how you doing?
You see that Yankee game,
last night?
What do they
got holes in their bats?
Yeah. Anyway, I got
to take your filing cabinet."
Also, these search warrants were
apparently a major operation
as they were conducted
at multiple sites
against multiple people.
According to the Times,
FBI agents also executed
a search warrant
on Wednesday morning
at the Washington area home
of Victoria Toensing,
a lawyer close to Giuliani
who had dealings
with several Ukrainians
involved in the hunt
for information on the Bidens.
Toensing is a fringe
right-wing figure,
along with her husband,
Joe diGenova,
a former "Fox News" crazy person
who was also involved
in the Ukraine mess
and is currently suing
Mike Lindell
for jackin' his style.
You guys remember this guy,
the guy who looks like he got
put on a no fly list
or trying to sneak his own
salami through security
at LaGuardia?
"Hey, that's prescription
salami. I got low salt."
What does this say about you
when these are your lawyers?
They look like
the kind of guys
who carry an extra neck
brace in their briefcase.
"Here, put this on.
Judges can't resist them."
Yeah, but it's
an embezzlement case.
"Okay, you want to go to jail?
Be my guest."
Rudy and Joe met when
they shared an office
out of the trunk
of a taxi cab.
"I got a big case, here,
help me move the spare."
So there's a whole web
of weirdos involved in this.
For the moment, the feds are
apparently homing in on Rudy.
For one thing, they reportedly
seized his electronic devices,
which is no small thing,
since he apparently has at least
three different cell phones
and one iPad,
according to a reporter
who profiled him for New York
magazine in 2019
and one hand, he clutch
three phones of varying sizes.
Two of the devices
were unlocked,
their screens
revealing open tabs
and a barrage
of banner notifications
as they knocked into each other
and reacted to Giuliani's grip.
"Do you have all three phones?"
his bodyguard said
as Giuliani
stepped out of the car.
"Yeah, I got all three phones,"
he said.
"I got to get down to two.
I'm going to try that tonight."
He did even better.
He got down to zero.
Also, what do you mean
you have to get down
from three phones to two?
Does he think he has
to physically combine them?
"I just need some duct tape."
Just stop using one of them.
You know, you can sync all your
devices on the cloud. Right?
Although I'm guessing the only
cloud Rudy's familiar with
is the one that follows
him around all day,
like Charlie Brown.
Not only does Rudy
cycle through phones,
he cycles through phone numbers,
which has created
the bizarre situation
of totally random people
inheriting his old phone numbers
and getting weird calls
as a result.
According to reporters
who keep in touch with him,
"He changes numbers
somewhat randomly,"
one White House
reporter said.
"So you never really know
if you're texting
the right number."
Personally, I have
half a dozen numbers
for Giuliani saved.
I just spoke to a man
who has had one of Rudy's
old numbers for about a month.
"Really?!" he said, when I told
him who used to have it.
He added that it explained
the odd calls he's been getting.
So some poor guy has probably
been getting inundated
with phone calls
from Ukrainian mobsters,
debt collectors,
and customer service
at Ritz Crackers calling back
to let him know
he can't book a three night stay
because they're not a hotel.
Also, I'm surprised the feds
even had to raid his house.
If they wanted the information
on his devices.
All they had to do
was watch "Fox News,"
where he kept showing
off his phone and iPad
and implicating various people
in his schemes
to dig up dirt on Biden
during the election.
-I never talked to
a Ukrainian official
until the State Department
called me
and asked me to do it.
And then I reported
every conversation back to them.
It's all here, right here.
The first call
from the State Department.
Here's Kurt saying
"Great. I will tell Yermak
and he'll visit with you there.
Thanks."
"Mr. Mayor, How was your meeting
with Andriy?
Do you have time for a call?
Best Kurt."
They're all over me
asking me to do it.
I was happy to do it.
-I guess Rudy is
one of those guys
who lines up outside
the Apple store
whenever their new product
comes out.
And how many bytes do you need?
[ As Giuliani ] None.
If the feds come after me,
I could swallow it whole.
[ Normal voice ] And how nice to
take a stroll down memory lane.
Remember when the president
and his goons
were so cartoonishly corrupt,
we all had to know names
like your Yermak, Zelensky,
Parnas, and Frooman?
Now the only
controversial name
in the Biden administration
is Major.
I'm pretty sure Yermak
was a Johnny Carson character.
"Please welcome Yermak
the Magnificent
all the way from Dijibouti.
Dijibouti, which is also
the name of Gary Hart's yacht.
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-You milked that so hard.
I'm going to start
calling you YoYo Moo.
-[ Laughs ]
-So it's very possible
there's a ton
of evidence
on those devices,
especially when you consider
that an independent judge
had to sign off
on these warrants against
such a high profile figure
the last time a raid like this
happened to one of Trump's
ex-lawyers.
The lawyer went to jail
and Trump was included
as an unnamed coconspirator
in the indictment.
And not only do we know
about the various communications
Rudy bragged about
on television,
we also know about his various
accidental communications,
the ones that weren't supposed
to get out into the public.
Like the time in 2019
he accidentally
butt dialed
a reporter for "NBC News"
and could be overheard
discussing various
foreign countries
he was entangled with
and a mysterious need for cash.
-There's also some odd news
today concerning this man,
Rudy Giuliani.
There is no elegant way
to put this,
but he butt dialed an "NBC News"
reporter last week,
inadvertently leaving
a voicemail message
that no one was supposed
to hear.
-Tomorrow, I gotta get you to
get on Bahrain.
You gotta call.
You gotta call Robert again
tomorrow.
Is Robert around?
-Rob, he's in Turkey.
-The problem is we need
some money.
We need a few hundred thousand.
-Jesus, no wonder they never
asked Rudy to wear a wire.
He is a wire.
And look, I'm sure there's
a perfectly innocent explanation
for why the president's lawyer,
who spends all his time
cycling through phone numbers
and jet setting across the world
with various unsavory characters
trying to manufacture dirt
on political opponents
would mysteriously need
a few hundred thousand dollars.
Maybe he needs it for
an emergency neck transplant.
[ As Giuliani ]
They finally found me a donor.
A giraffe at the Bronx Zoo
died of natural causes.
[ Normal voice ] And then, of
course, there was also the time
he called Alabama
Senator Tommy Tuberville
after a violent insurrection
at the Capitol
to try to get Tuberville
to continue delaying
the counting
of electoral votes.
While Trump and Rudy figured out
a way to keep Trump in power.
-Senator Tuberville?
Or I should say Coach
Tuberville.
This is Rudy Giuliani,
the president's lawyer.
There are 10 states that we
contest, not three.
So if you could object
to every state and,
along with a congressman,
get a hearings for every state,
I know we would delay you a lot,
but it would give us
the opportunity
to get the legislators
who are very,
very close
to pulling their vote.
-Say what you want about Rudy,
but I think it's nice
that he said Coach Tuberville.
So Senator Tuberville heard it.
He knew Rudy was a friend.
Of course, the problem
was Giuliani
dialed the wrong number and left
a voicemail for another senator
who in turn provided
the audio to the dispatch,
which released the message,
"Senator Tuberville?
or should I say Coach Tuberville
or should I say perfect stranger
who is currently confused
by the message
and who,
if they are polite,
we'll stop listening now
and delete this message.
And remember, these are just
the publicly available tests
and phone calls
we know about.
Can you imagine
what else is on there?
And apparently it's a lot
because the feds spent
a while carrying stuff
out of Rudy's apartment.
How do we know that?
Not from the feds themselves
or even from the press
necessarily,
but from one
of Rudy's neighbors,
a tenant in his building
who spoke to the press
and quickly became one of the
best parts of this whole saga.
-I just saw people
I probably saw FBI jackets,
but I just saw people, you know,
and I saw all of you.
And and and I said.
"What is going on?"
They're, probably maybe still up
there in his apartment.
I really don't know.
They were bringing out
a lot of stuff, right.
The funniest thing is my
ex-husband called me and said,
"Have you seen what's going on?"
And I said he said,
"No, look out your window."
-Wow. It's not even
Saturday night.
And Kate McKinnon is already
doing new characters.
This lady's incredible.
What were they thinking?
You can't just leave
a microphone unattended
on the Upper East Side,
otherwise the whole thing's
going to turn into
a community board meeting,
instantly.
[ As man ] I just want to say,
please don't put your hands
inside the bins at Zabar's.
Use the scope.
[ As Younger Man ] Yeah, hello.
I just want to say,
if you're looking for a deal
on New Balance,
come by my apartment.
I got a guy.
[ As Elder Man ] Yeah. If you
people are going to keep
bringing your dogs
on the elevator,
wipe their paws, okay?
People live here.
[ As woman ] Yeah, I know
the CDC said stop wearing masks,
but if you've got coffee breath,
you know, keep it on.
[ Normal voice ] Wouldn't be
surprised if during the raid
there was a guy across
the hall in his pajamas.
He had just eaten a bagel
bothering the agents.
[ As Young Man ]
What are you guys doing?
[ Normal voice ] Sir, this is a
law enforcement investigation.
We can't comment.
[ As Young Man ] Okay, okay.
Forget about it. You guys see
the Yankee game last night?
What do they got holes
in their bats?
Oh, you're taking the filing
cabinet? Interesting.
[ Normal voice ]
Now, as for Rudy,
he issued a statement
in which he claimed
the Biden administration
was targeting him.
And his son, Andrew, who worked
in the Trump administration,
gave a press conference
defending his father.
-Any American, whether
you were red or blue,
should be extremely disturbed
by what happened here today,
by the continued politicization
of the Justice Department.
If this can happen to
the former president's lawyer,
this can happen
to any American.
-Alright. First of all,
you look and sound
like a character from a
mid-2000s Will Ferrell comedy.
Who is your law partner?
Owen Wilson.
[ AS Wilson ]
Hey, Andrew, do you know
what habeas corpus means?
Sounds like some sort of spell.
[ Normal voice ] And yeah, we're
not doing Vince Vaughn today.
I got your feedback
loud and clear.
So now we can't have
nice things.
Also what do you mean?
If they can do this to Rudy,
they could do it to anyone.
I'd be more worried that
if they couldn't do it to Rudy,
they couldn't do it to anyone.
Well, they couldn't
even get Rudy.
Guess we live in a nation
without laws.
Isn't that the point, though,
that no one is above the law
and the president's lawyer
gets the same treatment
as everyone else?
I never understood this
argument from Republicans.
They said the same thing
during Trump's impeachment.
If they can do this
to the president,
they can do it to you.
Yeah, that's how it works.
These guys are genuinely
shocked to find out
that no one is above the law.
Oh, what's next?
Is my father going to start
getting tickets
for parking his car
on the BQE?
Don't worry, I left the note.
Rudy has denied the allegations,
so who knows what will
happen going forward.
But it is obviously not a small
thing for the feds to decide
there's enough evidence
to raid the home and office
of one of the former
president's closest confidants.
When the feds showed up
to Rudy's apartment
to take his phone,
he was probably like --
-It's all here.
Right here.
-This has been A Closer Look.
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button,
stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated, we love you.